good morning hank it's tuesday morning
he's here
it's a reunion spectacular
oh i feel like you're getting stronger
as you get older uh god well thanks i
feel like there's some
well
hank if you had a chance to rename
twitter what would you name it here's
the brand okay careful exclamation point
careful careful careful what are your
go-to
2021 holiday gifts a nice towel yeah a
good towel
is great you know what i would recommend
signed copies of the anthropocene
reviewed book
which are available with a special zine
written by me that contains an all-new
review and also written by lots of other
people at dftba.com link in the
doobly-doo all proceeds go to charity i
want to move the camera further away
from us so that we are both in frame
what is the thing about yourself that
you dislike the most let's switch it
around what is the thing about the other
person that you dislike the most what's
one of the ones that people say in
interviews i think john cares too much
yeah i think he just cares too much and
he works too passionately yes i would
say that both hank and i are a little
much oh yeah i mean i have spent a lot
of time wondering like what the inside
of your head is like over the years
because you're the person i've known the
longest it's funny to realize that the
inside of heads are very different even
the other day you tweeted that like you
don't feel guilty for your thoughts you
sent me a follow-up text to try to like
explain
i was worried yeah yeah you were like i
don't want you to think that i'm like a
bad person and i was like no i don't
think you're a bad person i think you're
enlightened you can have a thought and
understand that it's just a thought that
a thought is not an action right and i
would be totally embarrassed if people
knew about the thought but they don't
yeah you understand that they don't just
like an ocean it's an ocean of thoughts
yeah but then you pick up one little
drop of water and you're like oh this
thought is very dangerous and weird and
i don't like it and so i'm gonna keep
thinking about it and then there are now
there are two drops of water and now
there are four and now there are 16 and
now they're 32 and etc i do that but
with uh sock sales techniques
serious question not related to question
tuesday do you think you can take your
talent for selling socks which i would
argue is genuinely unparalleled
and apply it to
coffee it's a different challenge can
you do it hank but i bet i could i love
that self-belief i had a great book
sales idea john great well what was it
for like when when anthropocene reviewed
is white listed or whatever whitelisted
white labeled white labeled when the
publisher is like we have too many of
these when it is remaindered my idea is
to instead of signing them yeah um sign
two dollar bills and call it a two
dollar discount oh that's good one time
i was at a book sorting facility and
they were like there's a copy of your
book paper towns here's the machine
where through an algorithm or whatever
it either gets kicked into this row and
goes back to the warehouse or it goes
down uh this chute to be
pulped in a machine that like looks like
a the garbage compactor from star wars i
wonder what's going to happen with your
book paper towns you watched it i
watched it get kicked on
to the conveyor belt and again
and then chomped were they like that's
normal
yeah yeah that's what they were like
that's the way the cookie crumbles hank
what do you want to be when you grow up
oh
um
i think an author i would love i can't
guarantee that though because i don't
know if i can write a book i know i can
write two specific books yeah i know i
can write the books i've already written
i always thought that once you write a
book you know how to do it you don't i
know as little about how to write the
book that i am currently writing as i
knew about how to write looking for
alaska 15 years ago yeah it's so
different or actually
18 years ago
oh god we have to go hank i'll continue
to see you right now
you're fine you're doing great
we're all gonna die